[Música]
la historia cuenta que fue creada para
salvar a la última cabra salvaje
entonces amenazada en el corazón de la
saboa el parque nacional de lava nuez
atrae cada año a miles de senderistas En
búsqueda de Aire puro y una naturaleza
intacta un territorio conservado que
cuenta con no menos de un centenar de
Cumbres de 3000 metros o más donde se
puede descubrir la montaña de otra
manera Este es el límite del Parque de
la vanuas los animales Es como si lo
supieran lo conocieran viaje de Cold es
guía y fotógrafo conoce de memoria estos
relieves y la fauna que se esconde en
ellos para hacerla descubrir propone
casas fotográficas en raquetas para
caminar en la medida en que el ascenso
sea más escarpado más levantaremos el
talón para hacer salir Las garras que
tenemos aquí tal Como los gatos podremos
clavar Las garras esta familia de León
vino para desconectarse por los grandes
espacios Y por supuesto por los pero
será necesario ser paciente Aquí vemos
las dos uñas de nuestro siervo
una gran pezuña que podría decirse que
es un animal que se está volviendo de
montaña
nuestro senderistas continúan su camino
llevan dos horas recorriendo este macizo
solo en el mundo y su paciencia
terminando
en el objetivo de viaje se revela la
silueta En la cima
[Música]
vimos un rabecco En la cima lo vimos de
lado pudimos ver sus cuernos hay que
caminar
tras un buen esfuerzo llega la
recompensa un encuentro con rebecos y es
toda nuestra imaginación que se pone a
galopar cuando no lejos de ahí creemos
Escuchar lobos pero nada de pánico son
tan solo los 80 perros del Sayula que
piden su desayuno no se trata de
alimentar animales de compañía sino
atletas de alto rendimiento su deporte
el trineo su especialidad la velocidad
son los perros de la fiebre del Oro Los
buscadores de oro querían perros tan
resistentes como el Husky de Siberia
pero más rápido porque en la época de la
fiebre del Oro el primero que llegaba a
las concesiones de oro era el primero
que iba a aprovechar entonces había una
noción de competencia
para estos turistas empieza una
expedición digna de las novelas de
Aventuras dos horas de paseo en trineo
entre los pinos al ritmo del atalaje
[Música]
aquí todo es pasto de montaña durante el
verano Hay vacas la granja arriba no
está habitada en el invierno pero en el
verano hay una persona que viene para
vigilar sus vacas
Elsa aprovecha para transmitir su saber
hacer de conductora de trineo
pon tu pie en el centro sobre la barra y
listo saltas encima
perfecto entendiste ustedes entendieron
también a mal de nueve años aprende
rápido a otros les cuesta más
es muy físico es más físico que el esquí
todos los músculos del cuerpo trabajan
Pero vale la pena para completar la
sensaciones algunos están dispuestos a
mojarse a 1.300 metros de altura
mientras estos 15 centímetros de espesor
son cortados en esta capa de hielo está
valiente mujer se apresta a hacerle
frente al desafío de bucear en este lago
helado supongo que el cabello no debe
salir por aquí desde los pies hasta la
cabeza Fanny se pone un traje de 7
milímetros de espesor pesado Que así más
lento cada movimiento es necesario para
resistir lo que espera tengo miedo de
tener frío no la había elegido
mi marido me lo ofreció de Navidad
me encontré por lo tanto frente un hecho
cumplido No pude prepararme mucho
psicológicamente
para Fanny es un bautizo de buceo en
medio de las montañas 20 minutos de
inmersión en un agua a un grado
detrás de la careta Se aprecia un mundo
casi cerrado y su techo de hielo debajo
del Lago helado no hay prácticamente
ninguna salida incluso para las Burbujas
de aire
una prueba para el cuerpo y el espíritu
en esta agua helada en la que los
músculos se contraen y la respiración se
acorta la clave es mantener la calma
para apreciar mejor el momento
[Música]
la cabeza bajo caminando sobre el hielo
es particular
el hecho de ver que todo está cerrado es
impresionante
pero súper que uno sea un loco por la
adrenalina Aprendiz de conductor de
trineo o un apasionado de la fauna
salvaje el macizo de la vanuaz ofrece
una desconexión total lejos de la
muchedumbre de las telecabinas